bonjour à vous pierre laurent merci
d'être avec nous en direct et france
alors cet entretien entre emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine la thèse
aussi de l'empoisonnement corps et
confirmés dont des laboratoires français
et russes quel est votre regard sur les
derniers avancements de la sphère alexeï
navalni dont l'état de santé oms
reprécise s'améliore selon l'hôpital où
il est soigné
écoutez je pense qu'il n'y a pas
réellement d'avancement sur cette
affaire les occidentaux y compris la
france post culture un empoisonnement
aux novices choc
la russie demande des éléments des
exercices mans en tout cas les résultats
des analyses ce qui ne lui sont pas
fournis on est dans une sorte de no
man's land où les informations circulent
ou ne circule pas d'un côté à l'autre
mais sans aucun effet réel concret ce
qui est très clair en revanche c'est que
si l'on sushis ou fait les services où
l'organisme qui aurait organisé l'emploi
cement l'empoisonnement des alexeï
navalni est vraiment fait de bras cassés
de pieds nickelés parce que l'agent
nolito qui est présenté comme quelque
chose de terrible d'extraordinaire type
tué des dizaines de milliers voire de
centaines de milliers de personnes n'est
pas capable de liquider un ancien agent
skripal
en angleterre où un opposant navalni en
russie c'est tout de même extraordinaire
c'est à dire que des services qui
normalement devrait pouvoir liquider
qu'ils veulent sans laisser beaucoup de
traces se mêlent les pieds dans le tapis
et donne les faire pour se faire battre
non seulement en guérissant navalni en
russie dans l'hôpital russe mais en plus
en acceptant de le transférer en
allemagne à l'hôpital de la charité à
berlin ou si vraiment il y avait un
empoisonnement
ce se serait immédiatement découvert or
il faut considérer que vraiment les
services russes
si l'état russe est impliqué là dedans
sont en dessous de tout ce ne sont
vraiment pas des professionnels
autre élément pierre laurin vous vous
êtes d'accord vous avec la thèse aussi 7
les médecins ont sauvé la vie finalement
alexeï navalni je crois que lui ont
sauvé la vie dans la mesure où il est
arrivé dans l'hôpital dont une très
mauvaise condition et qui l'ont
stabilisé et non seulement ils ont
stabilisé mais ils ont permis son
transfert
medic par avion médicalisé jusqu'à
berlin
ce ne sont pas ce n'est pas un
comportement de coupables potentiels
c'est plutôt le comportement normal d'un
pays normal qu'ils se retrouvent devant
une situation qui n'était absolument pas
prévu
tout le reste et bien peut-être
effectivement il ya des groupes en
russie qui veulent la mort de la vanille
ça on le sait que ne veulent ni n'est
pas très populaire mais les accusations
qui sont faites et l'ont directement au
kremlin
hélas le kremlin franchement si
effectivement c'est lui qui a organisé
cela est bien il n'est pas à la comment
dirais-je à la mesure de ce qu'on
imagine de lui c'est plutôt qu'ils se
seraient comportés plutôt comme une
république bananière comme un grand état
comme la russie donc elle la thèse de
l'empoisonnement téléguidé par le
kremlin
à mon avis il ne tient pas beaucoup en
revanche ce qui est très clair c'est que
cette affaire comme beaucoup d'autres
avant elle intervient à un moment
relativement important dans les
relations entre les états occidentaux et
la russie est là actuellement ce qui est
en jeu c'est la construction non du
pardon ou du moins la fin de la
construction du gazoduc nord stream 2
qui est contestée en particulier par les
états unis qui aimerait plutôt que
que ce soit la russie qui fournissent de
l'énergie à l'europe par l'intermédiaire
du gazoduc
que ce soit les états unis qui forme qui
fournissent du glas de schiste par
bateau à travers de l'atlantique à
l'europe est elle là il ya peut-être une
concomitance qui est à mon avis
peut-être significative dernière édition
un tien lorrain pourquoi à votre avis
berlin ne fournit pas des éléments de
preuve comme le demande mouscou je crois
que c'est une question que l'on est en
droit de se poser depuis très longtemps
les occidentaux ne fournit jamais les
éléments de preuves pour soutenir les
allégations qu'ils avancent c'est vrai
dans la sphère de deux skripal par
exemple c'est vrai dans la sphère plus
ancienne du vol de la malaisienne
airlines abattu au dessus de l'ukraine
en 2014
c'est vrai dans de nombreuses affaires
on accuse moscou en disant nous détenons
des points mais seulement ses proches
restent secrètes
pour des raisons qui ne font pas très
compréhensibles par exemple on ne peut
pas dans cette affaire actuel de navalni
on ne peut pas comprendre quelles sont
les raisons de confidentialité qui
empêcherait les allemands de transmettre
les résultats de leurs analyses et les
éléments les échantillons qui ont permis
de les dresser aux russes est ce que
c'est parce que ces échantillons là ne
sont pas aussi fiables qu'ils le
prétendent ses possibles est ce parce
que il ya une défiance globale des
occidentaux des services toutes sortes
de services confondus pas seulement les
services secrets mais également on voit
l'administration de la justice en
allemagne où les services hospitaliers
en allemagne 6e messi de la russie des
réactions de peut-être une des
accusations de collusion avec les russes
enfin on est dans le
dans une situation qui est très
schizophrénique on ne comprend pas très
bien quels sont les tenants et les
aboutissants et quelles sont les
motivations des différents acteurs
occidentaux
quant au russe est bien la seule chose
qu'ils demandent c'est des éléments qui
leur permettent effectivement de
vérifier il ya eu emplois zone man ou
pas les médecins russes n'ont pas
détecté d'empoisonnement est ce qu'on
peut leur faire confiance ou non ça fait
une autre histoire mais en tout cas s'il
vous tiennent rené mérite d'être
comparée et merci à vous pierre le rhin
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste écrivain spécialiste de la
russie